[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to spectacv I'm James
seal the spectator's political
correspondent and your host this week
coming up on the show
please guys in France I mean satellite
been men are striking and protesters are
violently clashing with police Jonathan
Miller and Andrew Neal will be joining
me to discuss the backlash to macron's
pension reforms back in the UK whomzy
Yusuf was narrowly elected the leader of
the s p what challenges does he now face
are we speaking to Ian mcwhirter
in Westminster this week Tories are
siding with the s p over an MP
suspension refugees could soon move from
hotels to ships and Corbin won't be
standing for labor at the next election
Katie balls will be joining us to talk
through it all
should MPS have second jobs and
undercover sting show Matt Hancock tries
to charge 10 000 pounds a day for a fake
consultancy Douglas Mario is sharing his
thoughts on the crisis of confidence
facing our Parliament and finally the
campaigner Posey Parker writes for this
week's magazine about a tour down under
she'll be on the show to tell us all
about it
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator TV then do subscribe to our
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss
another episode and if you want to read
more than spectator then why not
subscribe to the magazine for just 12
pounds you can get 12 weeks in printing
online and a free 20 pound Amazon
voucher just go to
www.spectady.co.uk forward slash TV
offer to subscribe
first up spectator contributor Jonathan
Miller writes this week's cover piece
about macron's pension reforms why is he
so desperate to pass them Jonathan joins
me now with the spectators chairman
Andrew Neal
this week in spectator magazine Jonathan
Miller writes about the protests in
France I'm joined Now by Jonathan and
chairman spectator Andrew Neil welcome
both uh Jonathan first question has
macron gone too far
well I think macron is uh is uh showing
in his second term his weaknesses from
his first term which is you know he's
actually right about what else France he
came into office with a great reforming
agenda but he just annoys everybody the
first time around he increased the tax
on diesel fuel while suppressing the
world tax that started the Julie Jones
movement which really only petered out
with covid and now he's kind of doing it
all over again he's he's pushing the uh
pushing the uh the reform of the pension
agenda oh and he's right to do so and
he's meanwhile you know continuing to
manifest the Marie Antoinette
quality of hiding his wristwatch mine is
not a a 4 000 Euro wristwatch just to be
clear
um Andrew I mean Jonathan says macron's
right to go ahead with these reforms
um and it seems you know largely Common
Sense here having a retirement age of
62. a ironically public appalling is
against him you've got a lot of students
you'll have to pay the debts of these
things for decades to come how has
macrame got it so spectacularly wrong
and why doesn't he be able to seem able
to communicate his message clearly
well since we're in a mood of full
disclosure I I have got a watch which is
at least 4 000 Euros
um probably a lot more you're a white
colonialist you're a that's a gift from
my wife who is half Persian so be
careful what you say and
um I'm not taking it off in fact I'm
rather proud of it but then I'm not
president of France uh
Jonathan's cover story uh at The
Spectator this week which is superb it
has actually a brilliant cover based on
tune as well which is very funny uh it
makes two very strong points one is that
French pensions do need to be reformed
there's no way the French State can
continue to afford the level of Pensions
it pays
um with everybody retiring well with
people retiring at the latest 62 uh
train drivers retire earlier the nario
traffic controllers uh retire earlier
than that all in a pretty good quack as
well pensions account for 14 of French
GDP as it is that will rise it's way
above even the European average so he's
right to go down this road previous
presidents have made some changes to
Sarkozy made some changes even along the
Socialist president made some changes
the problem is the one that Jonathan
alludes to is that this reform wouldn't
be so nearly so unpopular
if it was being proposed by President
macron he just does seem to have the
ability to wind people up even when he's
right and it goes back to the whole
Jupiter I am God of gods I mean he is
very Grand he makes our royal family
look quite common actually and so he
can't be happy with the King being in
the bundestag today and I think that
says it's it's a it's a great pity in a
way because he's right it will have to
be done by somebody but he struggles to
carry public opinion uh with him so
that's why at the moment you've got the
standoff
and Jonathan obviously you know cited
public polling there's obviously the
protesters who are getting all the you
know the pictures and the films is there
not some kind of you know section of the
French public maybe not a silent
majority but uh a certainly a sizable
minority which agrees with him and
accepts this or is this just seen as a
sort of elite project
well there are there are some people in
France who agree with him although they
don't particularly want to identify with
him personally he never really uh has
received a lot of regulation of the
French people he was elected on both
occasions mainly because people thought
the alternative Marine Le Pen was
actually worse he had no native
political party he has no great core of
support outside the media where he's had
a lot of a lot of support and foreign
journalists who have loved him the
economists had him on their cover
walking on water uh the new you know the
New York Times thinks he's the greatest
thing since you know slice sliced
baguette
um but no he doesn't have a huge I mean
people who want to know better in France
just have not had it explained to them
how you know people are living longer
um and who and somebody's got to pay for
these generous retirements I mean even
high school students they're
demonstrating uh in against this reform
when they have they don't seem to have
cotton onto that it's them who's going
to spend their entire working lives
paying for Jacques my friend down at the
allotments in my Village who retired at
51 against 2500 Euros he's a railway guy
he has 2500 Euros a month and could well
be drawing that for 30 years well
unfortunately somebody's got to pay for
that I mean I'm very happy for Chuck
he's a very happy guy and that's great
but but some you know somewhere they've
got to stop binging and deal with the
bill which they simply refuse to do
Andrew you mentioned there about um
macron's uh sort of Jupiter complex do
you think that's why he thought he could
succeed when so many sort of efforts to
change this immersively Jacques Chirac
in 1995 did he think he could succeed
where others had failed because of
Hebrews perhaps
well I mean I think he thinks he can do
things that other presidents have not
been able to do but he hasn't prepared
the ground very well uh for it there was
an argument to be one here of course
it's all been exacerbated by the fact he
hasn't got a majority in the French
Parliament and the National Assembly and
so could only get it through by
exercising the executive powers created
by De Gaulle in 1958 of this famous
Clause 49.3 of the French Constitution
which allowed him to push it through
basically by executive Fiat and of
course that added there for a lack of
sort of democratic legitimacy has added
to the demonstrations
but
I think it's pretty clear there's a good
report in the online by The Spectator
but by Gavin Mortimer from the
demonstrations on Tuesday he was with
them in Paris they didn't seem to be
nearly on the same scale as the previous
week and there isn't another one coming
up till April the 6th which will be next
week and I think it'd be interesting to
see if there is momentum or whether
actually they're beginning to tell off a
little bit uh that um that actually
they're not becoming uh on a scale that
Force Shirak president Shirak to turn
back in 1995 after he had won both the
presidency and the National Assembly by
a landslide the president is um in the
uh result Alps today which isn't all
that far from where I'm talking to you
from he's visiting a reservoir because
there's a major water shortage problems
developing in this region they're
already water controls here Year and
much isn't even out yet so he's trying
to say his business as usual he was met
by some demonstrators but not by that
many I guess he'll he'll be willing to
see what happens through April to see if
there is momentum which will make the
protester resistible or whether actually
they're going to fade out the one thing
that puzzles Me Maybe Jonathan can shed
some light on this is that what did for
Shirak in 95 is that the unions
basically brought the country to a halt
um everything stopped it was like the
effect of a general strike and it was
indefinite they just carried on until
Shirak gave in the unions actually true
in Britain as well the unions in Britain
and definitely now in France they don't
seem to do that they they go on strike
for a while they cause disruption then
they go back to work again which kind of
mitigates the impact they're really
having
meanwhile of course you know the air
traffic controllers who've been causing
disruption right across Europe are still
planning to continue that assertion you
know whether macron can win technically
on point this battle or not I think that
uh what I conclude in this piece is that
he has uh succeeded really in uniting
most of the French against him he
doesn't have a lot of a lot of political
Capital to persuade the French
um to to bend to his will I think he's
going to be spending a lot more time
posturing on the international stage but
the question really now needs to be
raised is whether Jupiter's presidency
is a failure and unless he can pull some
kind of remarkable
um uh rabbit out of his hat or rat out
of his hat given what's happening in
Paris
um I just don't see where he goes uh
henceforth
um I think it's it's a you know he's a
sort of a somewhat helpless uh figure
who has uh has uh has has failed to to
carry the French along with him and I
think there's nothing much he can do to
change his personality he may be
brilliant he may be right but uh but
people are not uh people are not
convinced by him and I don't see that
changing and Jonathan if macron does
fail who stands to benefit from that
you're writing your piece about marila
Penn who's uh sort of been indulging in
some of the uh economic unreality of
this and agreeing with the pensioners
but keeping quite a moderate rhetoric
who if macron is seen as a failure or
who will run against that record next
time
well I think the the immediate evident
beneficiary is Marine Le Pen who's
played you know to me a surprisingly
smart game she hasn't been hysterical
she's on the wrong side uh of the
pension reform she wants to actually
lower it uh to 60 which is economically
suicidal but she's not issuing blood
curdling threats so she's an immediate
beneficiary it's hard to you can look
around the Horizon as a lot of people
want a macron's job there's Edward
Philippe the former prime minister maybe
he's credible but unfortunately the uh
the the talent on the bench here is not
that impressive and it doesn't look like
there's anybody uh willing to step
forward and and Lead France to A Renewed
Glory at the moment which is why uh it's
it's it's it's a it's a it's sort of a
sad situation for France that their
their caught between this kind of
inability to accept reality and a
political system that is not not really
responding to the needs of the country
or convincing voters of a Way Forward
faced with all that Andrew do you think
macron's going to press on amount to
climb down which we've seen so many
politicians do before or do you reckon
that he's going to carry on with these
reforms and think he's not going to run
again and Press On Come What May well I
think that if the unions succeeded in
bringing the country to a halt as they
did under President Shirak he would have
to find some way of backing down because
chaos would result if the unions and
their supporters carry on the way
they're going at the moment but he could
actually scrape through this and can
continue as I say he's trying to give an
impression of business as usual there
are issues at stake here of which
branches France illustrates but go Way
Beyond France and speak to all of Europe
I mean the harsh reality is that
European welfare states European social
democracies are now kept afloat on a
massive sea of red ink uh the welfare
state survives by borrowing that that's
how it does it if you you know the one
at the outer extreme you've got Greece
whose national debt is over 170 percent
of its GDP if you think that's ever
going to be paid back I've got a bridge
to sell you
um Italy is over a hundred and thirty
percent France uh the biggest economy
after Germany is a hundred and thirteen
percent uh the only one that is anywhere
near the Mastery criteria which I remind
our viewers is that debt should not be
more than 60 of GDP that's supposed to
be the rules of the of the uh European
single currency is Germany so you've got
this massive CE of reading keeping the
welfare state afloat
I'm very other place a few places to go
in France the state now spends almost 60
percent of GDP I mean does anybody think
spending even more which is what keeping
the current pension system would be will
make France a more competitive Society I
don't think so I mean I guess you could
go to 100 what you get then is the
Soviet Union that well-known Innovative
Insurgent Dynamic economy
um you want to put taxis up well French
taxis are already the highest of any
major economy in Europe and I think
France is bordered by seven countries
it's quite easy for French people to get
out of their into their cars onto a
plane onto a train and Scoot out of the
country which is what they did when
previous presidents tried to put taxis
even higher than they are at the moment
so you can see not just friends but all
of Europe at the moment is between a
rock and a hard place on on this they
can't really borrow anymore they can't
really increase State spending anymore
unless they want to destroy what
dynamism is left in their economies
which in many cases isn't uh very much
and they you know they can't increase
taxes by anymore because that's pretty
much at a high level too the French
situation and France illustrates all of
the above and a large scale
is is also the the politics of it aren't
that great because the price of the rise
of mackerel
who uh and I'm reminded of Jonathan said
that the economist said you could walk
on water The Economist also put Angela
Merkel on the cover and said she was the
new leader of the Free World
um how has that played out it's why I
think more and more people have been
turning from The Economist to The
Spectator that speaks for itself
on on that
um but the price of the rise of macron
has been the destruction of the
mainstream right and the mainstream left
so if as Mr shirite did uh if he was to
call parliamentary elections I think
again as Jonathan alluded to it the main
beneficiaries would be the extreme left
and the extreme right particularly the
extreme right both the extreme left and
the extreme right are against the
pension reforms so there isn't even a
political way out of this either which I
think why which is why France is
interesting I mean our own prime
minister Mr sunac he's delayed the
pension raising the pension age again
the reason people should watch carefully
what's happening in France is because it
is important that the issues are alive
all over Europe like this at the moment
they're just at their most acute uh in
France for now fascinating Port 10 from
Paris thank you van Drew thank you
Jonathan
back home homes are Yusuf was elected as
sturgeon's successor this week
how has he started his reign as
Scotland's first Minister and the s p
party leader spectator contributor Ian
mcwherter joins me now
Ian um Hamza Yusuf won with just over 52
of the vote in a very split party surely
this is the sort of dream result that
unionists were hoping for
ah yeah from a universe point of view um
you know this is uh exactly how they'd
have liked it to play the SNP the
divisions emerged during the course of
this leadership campaign but no one
quite realized how profound these
divisions actually are and we can see
that in the result
Kate Forbes uh getting nearly half the
votes remember she was up against films
of Yusuf who had the entire resources of
the of the Scottish national party and
if we did the the government uh behind
him he was he was a continuity to Canton
he was the chosen candidate by Nicolas
sturgeon he was the one that they wanted
in there and it became a profound shot
that um Kate Forbes who of course
opposes many of the so-called
Progressive uh pieces of legislation
that uh Hamza yusa is determined to
proceed with like the gender recognition
Reform Bill it was a profound shock to
the SNP to discover
um you know that she was able to command
such a support from the membership and
also I think unionists will be well
pleased with hearing what was said
really not just between the lines but on
the lines during this campaign by all
three candidates you know one way or the
other that Independence is not going to
happen in in the near future that the
argument not been properly married they
need to win over and build Fortress
um and you know that that just makes the
case for the UK government to say well
yeah you're you know now is not the time
for another Independence referendum you
basically said to yourself go away and
think again
of course you know unionist is one label
and there's this big Divine Scottish
politics unionist versus nationalist but
there's also the two main unionist
parties of the conservatives and labor
how would you describe this result as
impacting upon their chances um you know
for instance some conservative spoke to
a delighted with humza Yusuf but they're
worried now about the impact they'll
have for labor and labor also you know
potentially would have wanted Kate
Forbes as a socially Conservative
candidate which might have given them a
bit more space on the left to talk us
through the kind of prospect for both
two main unionist parties now that honzo
Yusuf is the first minister
yeah yeah it is strange isn't it the
book of the unionist parties would have
preferred the socially conservative uh
Cape Forbes and as first Minister rather
than Hamza Yusuf and of course the main
reason there is that they both regard
humble's use of as a weak candidate he
was famous today given a dressing down
by Kate Forbes during the campaign
saying he could make the trains run on
time he lost a plot with the police
um you know he's the worst uh he was the
worst Health Minister that the the SNP
has had and she said she would suck him
as soon as she she won if she won so I
mean he has he has a lame duck first
Minister even before he took office
um as for the election prospects well
um labor obviously are looking now to
recover seats next year the general
election they can say now Scots have a
choice Nicholas Trojan always said the
reason we need Independence is because
Scotland keeps getting Tory garments for
which we do not vote and now this time
they have a chance to vote for a labor
government to vote to get the Tories out
of Investments so so it's going to be a
tremendous I think a very a very strong
motivation on many voters on the kind of
Social Democratic softlet in Scotland
who was saying well this time you know
we will be voting SNP for a few years
now this time we're going to go to labor
because we want to get the Tories out
and remember later
um you know labor had 41 out of 59 seats
in Scotland as recently as 2010. so
there is you know there is a history of
Labor voting here particularly labor
voting uh in UK elections which could
well they could well reconnect with now
they say they're going to get 20 seats
that's probably been optimistic but um
you know that would be be uh any I think
if they get double figures at the next
election that will be a blow to a
serious blow to Hamza Yusuf and the new
regime in-house
because here's labor basically doing the
progressive agenda and getting votes for
it as the choice they're in a very
difficult position I mean they are
relieved that they're not up against
Cape forms mainly because Cape Forbes
was a strong candidate and she kind of
talked on through a territory because
she was saying you know uh Progressive
legislation is all very well but you
know you've got to get the economy right
you've got to support you've got to talk
to business
um his cabinet he's completely wiped out
the cake Forbes faction there are no
Representatives not even her campaign
manager Ivan McKee who was the business
secretary even he's been effectively
ousted I mean by being given
um you know demeaning job opportunities
so they're they're right out in the back
benches the s p is very obviously
divided now and the Tories can you know
they can they will hope to be able to
pick up on the kind of themes that the
Kate Forbes put out during the um
campaign and use them in their own uh
election uh pitches but I mean you know
I think that I don't think they're going
to get much traction in the next
election because I think it's all going
to be about getting labor getting a
labor victory in Westminster so I don't
think they're gonna they're gonna make
much perhaps in the next Scottish
parliamentary elections a couple of
years on that that might be an
opportunity for them then so more 2026
then 2026 yeah because I mean I think
everyone expects that yourself is going
to have well a series of of um of
failures he's going to have he's going
to promote he's going to persevere with
this legal action against
um article uh section 35 of the Scotland
act under which the gender recognition
Act was blocked by the UK government on
the grounds that it concluded with the
uh with the equality legislation and um
yeah he he was he knocked from Pillar To
Post to this because at times he said
well you know I'd take the legal advice
and I wouldn't personally agree with
this if I thought it was going to be a
futile then he turns around the first
thing he says well actually the second
thing he says when he's I saw this first
Minister he's gonna he's gonna take the
UK government to court even though
everybody knows it would be it would be
a failure the second thing or the first
thing his first pronouncement of course
was he said I was gonna I'm going to
demand a section 30 order to get an
independence referendum and within hours
of becoming first manager so what did he
do he lifted up the phone to number 10
and asked for it and they said um no no
I don't think so and he said what could
he say you know so he's moved on so I
mean already you can see you can see
there's going to be a pattern of
failures here or or problems with a
background of economic failure which the
Tories I think will will probably be
able to make I can't remember the
tourism are the opposition party in
Hollywood and I think they'll be able to
make something of that probably in by by
the time of the 2026 elections if the
cape forms
um faction is still so isolated uh
because then the Tories could
conceivably win back support in the
northeast of Scotland the oil uh
industry remember hamzu says very Pearl
green here is very opposed so oil and
gas industry tourists could pick up
votes there and possibly even in
Highland constituencies
I mean you mentioned Kate Forbes there
um and there's an analogy which Katie
has drawn in her column which is about
um you know who's pointing a cabinet of
loyalists uh a bit like Liz truss of
course and there's always a very loyal
cabinet and the danger was of course it
sort of formed a rival Court a sort of
King over the water as it were do you
think there's perhaps a chance that Cape
Forbes and Ivan McKee
um and some of those who are less
enthusiastic about say The Party Machine
within the Parliament can sort of cause
any any sort of Mischief or problems to
himself
um either in the short term or over the
next couple of years until the Scottish
elections uh well I think they they will
but I don't think they immediately will
form some kind of rival logical party
there already is one remember in
Scotland there's Alba there's Alex
Salmon's party where now you know he's
always going to be in the sidelines here
he's he's risen to prominence again
during this campaign but you know that
is I think there will be a they will
the Forbes 48 percenters if you like
will um not want to be appear to be
allied with with another political party
so I think they'll be very cautious
about that however they don't really
need to do very much and they can allow
you know she's made her pitch very clear
she won this very substantial support
and all and everyone knows what she
stands for so she can watch
um you know from the back benches uh as
Hamza Yusuf you know collides with these
obstacles and doesn't really need to say
anything or organize any anything in
particular
um uh for for them for the media intern
obviously you know when it comes to 2026
uh things might look very different
um I mean some people are comparing
Ham's use of two uh Liz trust and
thinking he might not even be there by
that by that time I think that's
probably uh a bit fanciful I think he's
he should be around for for a bit at
least but it's going to be a rocky road
yeah we'll see in 49 days time if that
proves to be to correct I mean of course
homozy office is facing uh now his first
electoral challenge in the fact that the
likely by-election in Margaret ferrier's
constituency in West Hamilton
um you know mother Feria has been given
a Thursday suspension today
um by the Privileges committing the
House of Commons it'll likely go to vote
of MPS and thereafter you need to get 10
to constituents for a by-election if
there is such a contest um which may be
sort of three or four months away
um labor obviously were only sort of 5
000 votes behind last time surely Anna
Sawa and Scottish labor are now very
much looking forward to the chance of
taking on
um they're in this seat and potentially
winning all right another hot housing
butt actually no I I don't know um yeah
they will be they will be hoping that
they can make progress here I'm not sure
it's going to be as as easy as that
um I mean the SNP is quite dug into
these constituences and has been for a
long time
um but yeah yeah I mean they will uh
they will
particularly if there are some incidents
that take place in the next few weeks
some setbacks that humans are use of
um there is I mean you detect a
frustration with a number of the ways in
which he's conducted himself not least
holding this prayer meeting in uh the
the staterooms at Butte house on the
night he was installed as first Minister
I mean a lot of people are just saying
well it's a very strange thing too it's
like holding a prayer meeting and you
know the cabinet room and number 10 is
not something that you really do you try
to keep some kind of distance between
faith and politics so this appeared to
be bringing Faith right into the center
of government
um in Scotland and a number of people
have have been very uneasy about that
and you know a number of
of um uh you know really other religious
faced in Scotland
um I I don't speak from personal
knowledge here because I'm an atheist
but I mean a number of church leaders
other churches have said that we're very
concerned about the way in which Cape
force was Detroit force was demonized
for being a Christian uh while Hamza
Yusuf was his his adherence to what is a
socially conservative Faith somehow was
was glossed over and avoided so I think
there's you know you'll find Catholic
communities in West Central Scotland
um who are traditionally about Labor
will be slightly uneasy about this I
think I don't know if that's going to
make them vote uh against the SNP but
it's you know there's already a sense
that that
um Hunter Youssef is not a secure a safe
Pair of Hands in the way that is
predecessor Nicola sturgeon was and
that's the thing everyone's going to
make that comparison
yes and finally just to conclude Ian I
mean in her column uh Katie Ends by
saying unius now have a golden chance to
press their cause in the year ahead do
you agree with that assessment and um if
they do have a golden chance how best to
exploit it
well did you have a golden chance and as
I as I was saying you know I think for
the 2024 election I think they have a
very good chance particularly labor has
an extremely good opportunity to uh to
show that it still is relevant
politically in Scotland and the SNP has
been so dominant under Nicholas sturgeon
you know remember since 2015 when they
won you know 50 56 seats out of 59 and
labor was reduced to one seat they still
have more uh msps in the Scottish
Parliament uh than all the unionist
priorities combined and more NPS than
all the unionist priorities combine so
you know I mean Scots you know SNP is
very very dug in electorally in Scotland
and it's they dominate politics at every
level
um but this is so this is an opportunity
for labor in in 2024 to say that
actually reporting labor does matter
because you can actually change that you
can change the character of the
government in Westminster so you can
change the UK vote for us if you work
with SMB nothing's going to happen vote
for us and you know we'll kick those
stories out so that's going to be a very
that's that's going to be their
opportunity
um you know whether they can take it not
another matter because the properties
have been uh because they've been down
so long you know they don't really know
what you know it looks like up to them
there really are there have been they
have been the opposition parties have
been hollowed out in the last decade of
SNP rule
well thank you very much for that Ian
and now to give us the latest from
Westminster I'm joined by a political
editor Katie Bulls
last week Katie the big story of course
was that privileged Committee hearing on
the Wednesday afternoon and there's an
interesting kind of sequel to that in
something that's happened today talk us
through the 30-day suspension that's
been handed out by the Privileges
committee to Margaret Ferrier so this is
the former SMP who I think infamously
went on a trip during lockdown while
having covert and then was found out who
traveled and therefore broken the rules
and it's pretty steep punishment I think
partly because it is quite a serious
offense and the report was pretty
damning saying that Mark Ferry ever you
know awfully a legend she was dishonest
in various points in in terms of you
know this wasn't a blip of a mistake it
was an active you know decision and and
therefore it's going for a 30-day
suspension now as you allude to what is
interesting is they're free conservative
MPS and you know judging on this who do
not agree with the 30-day suspension and
suggested it should be smaller and we're
talking single figures
um which would of course mean that she
would not be suspended from Parliament
to the point to the level which could
trigger a recall petition that could
then trigger a by-election now have
these Tories suddenly become SMP
supporters or at least Margaret ferret
independent now supporters and they you
know want to prevent this by-election
which could be quite good for labor
um do they just think that the rest of
the committee is completely wrong and
actually it's quite a light offense oh
are they worried about precedent because
of course these MPS are also judging
Boris Johnson when it comes to partygate
and whether he misled did your old boss
Boris Johnson miss me Parliament you can
see that perhaps they don't want to get
behind this very long suspension uh in
the sense if they were to say a
precedent for then agreeing a very long
suspension or making it seem stranger
worthy to object to a long suspension
for Boris Johnson and I think it does
feed into something we are talking about
last week on the podcast on spectator TV
and and writing in the magazine which is
most tour MPS want to avoid a Boris
Johnson violation like the plague
um ironically yeah and they do not think
that this is um good news for the party
even those people who really do not like
Boris Johnson in the Tory party the idea
of a by-election continuing the Boris
Johnson circus and also uh potentially
leading either to um you know the tour
is losing a seat or an enhanced Boris
Johnson neither are particularly
appetizer into this tandemic street yes
you have to wonder which side which is
going to be campaigning on in that
by-election I believe I have no choice
but and so with the Thursday suspension
it's now going to be voted on by the
House of Commons that seems almost
inevitable it's going to pass
um the majority of which Margaret ferio
had the last election was just over five
thousand Scottish labor must be licking
their lips at the prospect of a win
there yeah and of course with the um
election this week of homeser Youssef as
the new first minister of Scotland SMP
leader it means he's going into an
immediate Challenge and a test of his I
suppose Authority now I think he has had
quite a significant role in Nicholas
surgeons government you can't say no
this is nothing to do with me what the
result comes so it'll be interesting
tests as to whether Scottish labor you
know is making these inroads um you know
where public satisfaction with the smps
are quite a bruising contest because
also there is something that which is
it's obviously been a difficult contest
for the s p
um but at the same time I think there's
now so much expectation that Scottish
labor are going to make huge inroads
there's also quite a lot of pressure on
labor to show that they can deliver
there and one of the other big stories
I've been dominating this week has been
migration again and the big news here
was on Wednesday when Robert General
came to House of Commons and outlined
what was going to happen to migrants in
hotels and that we moved out
um the plan is now for land sites talk
us through the kind of dynamics of that
Katie yeah so boat's been back in the
news for a few reasons so firstly a
legal migration bill was back in the
Commons this week and there was lots of
talk of rebellions and in the end I
think number 10 the whip surface managed
to talk down both sides um but by doing
that have given concessions so looking
at legal routes for some coming over
um at the moment it was just previously
it was just we will think about some
legal routes in the future I think that
would be toughened up so as to make more
routes and then also um those on the
right of the party wanting you know
stronger wording and in the bill towards
um being able to ultimately limit the
control of Judges
um when it comes to the echr and about
how these orders work now that's all
bubbling along and as you say the thing
that's potentially more controversial
this week is actually where are Asylum
Seekers when they come here staying now
we know that the issue of Asylum seekers
in hotels has become really politically
potent and and it's something that you
know lots of MPS are you know really
worry is going to be a massive electoral
factor for them and this is an effort to
say we're going to be moving these
people out we're going to massively
reduce the use of hotels and partly
through Naval bases and some talk of
ferries and ships and now I think that
what's interesting is there was already
a Tory backlash to some of this which is
ultimately not in my backyard so you
have a situation where you know some
senatories who have these Naval bases in
the area are not comfortable or
particularly pleased to say the least
and the idea they'll be you know both
having like a large base for this but I
think from the government perspective
probably annoying a lot of MPS and
voters all across the country or
targeting this to you know areas is as
soon as you know there is no win-win on
this politically so I think this is seen
as Improvement and we're hearing a lot
about uh potentially um you know off
offshoring in the sense of on boats not
the Rwanda scheme and has now this is
interesting because
it's still to be it's still to be
confirmed whether it's actually going to
happen it's more a government aspiration
and there's also a briefing from Summer
government saying well the home office
looked at support but it was so
expensive it was actually cheaper to put
them in hotels I think on this issue of
small boats it's it's no longer really
about money in the sense cleaning money
is a factor but I think it's about how
politically damaging it is and I think
paying more money to uh ultimately have
Asylum Seekers on boats it's less
politically painful than having them in
hotels all across the country I was
really struck by a line I read on
Wednesday which is that some figures in
government were briefing out that saying
well this is a fight we want to have as
you say it's not so much about money
it's also about kind of choosing a
political battle the government think
they can really win on this after all
the promises they've had before so I
think there's been a bit of a changing
in the mood music in recent weeks
whereas it's a bit more optimism that
Rishi Knight will be able to deliver
perhaps not stop the boats full stop but
something that is still the case if you
look at the expected number of how the
number of Crossings are rising I think
there could be some really difficult
figures for the government but what
they're doing here is they've got about
you know several different aspects that
they're trying to push here so you have
yes the legal migration bill you have
the reduction of the use of hotels you
have this scheme of Albania to stop
there and then you also have cooperation
with France and I think that there's a
sense there's no Silver Bullet but if
you do all these things and also I think
there is definitely at least a look of
movement from the public the other
government doing it then it but at least
in the run-up to the next election the
government will be able to say well we
are doing things and we're starting to
see some progress and I actually think
the difficult thing for labor is I think
in Downing streaming across government
if they can just get one flight to
Rwanda obviously that alone would not
have deterrent effect but you take all
these things together and you look at
the fact that Labor's main attack or the
Tories is simply your schemes don't work
this is unworkable they don't want to go
near Morality In the slightest and
leverage you can start to get you know
just a few flights to Rwanda I think
there is a sense of this would change
some mood music and mean that there's a
lot more faith in the government now
there's been lots of you know fall
storms false promises
um but I think that is the strategy and
why people are a bit more optimistic you
mentioned labor there of course the big
story that was dominating that party
this week uh was Jeremy corbyn being
barred from this motion uh passed by the
national executive Council on Tuesday
um what do you think I mean some people
say that you know Kirsten likes having
Jerry Corbin as a sort of political
pinata basically to give a kicking and
sort of distant cell from the left what
do you think Stalin was thinking on all
this is and How likely is it that Corbin
can actually stand and pose a challenge
in Islington again so I think that's an
interesting one we know that kier's
Dharma has tried to Define himself and
partly having a fight with his own side
um I think it's part because he's
struggling when he gets these Mission
speeches to really light up the country
in enthusiasm but perhaps we just
haven't seen the right Mission speech
yet
um and therefore you have a situation
whereby you know ultimately when he
suspended Jeremy corbyn
um over you know his comments on an
anti-Semitism report that was I think
appointment actually uh loads around
here stamina think that it really helped
show that labor had changed and banning
Jeremy corbyn which was the vote this
week which has happened from standing as
a labor cancer in the next election it's
almost a completion of this journey I
think
um will it work in the same way I think
this has the potential to be much
Messier as you say Jeremy corbyn has
hinted he could stand as an independent
it's not so much if you think about you
know isn't enough it's a very safe seat
so it's not so much that Jeremy corbyn
might win I think that seems unlikely
um and I also think you know it's not so
the Tories will really go through in the
middle there I would be surprised but
it's I think it's an interesting
question as to if in the lead-up to the
general election there was quite a messy
situation where Jeremy corbyn's
campaigning as an independent there are
quite a few labor members who support
Jeremy Corbin still particularly the
younger you know younger labor voters
um you know saying you know evil care
starmus stopping this no democracy in
the labor party and then you have your
labor candidate who's been vetted is
that something where everyone says well
great kissed armor you've pushed this
guy to the side or does it just remind
people of Labor Civil Wars and I think
the jury is out right now on whether
this will you know be a boon to kirst
armor are actually quite tricky
fascinating question which will continue
to make thank you for joining me Katie
that was Mario writes in this week's
magazine about MPS having second jobs it
follows a sting by the campaign group
led by donkeys who tried to trap MPS
into green to do consultancy work for a
fake South Korean company to explain
what happened and to make sense of it
Douglas joins me now
hello and thank you for joining us
Douglas um you've written your column
this week on MP's second jobs tell us
what exactly inspired that one
well there's several things one is of
course it's a perennial subject in
British politics his question of whether
or not MPS can or should have second
jobs it's a perennial discussion because
it's sort of clear and unclear
um the clear thing is of course being an
MP clearly isn't a full-time job
otherwise people couldn't join the
cabinet uh or the shadow cabinet on the
other hand seems that there are certain
jobs
mainly money making jobs which people
don't appreciate MPS taking
and then the more sort of urgent thing
is the release this week of footage by
the campaigning group led by donkeys
which was a sort of classic tabloid
sting of various MPS the
this group pretended to be a South
Korean company looking for people to sit
on it sort of Advisory Board and be paid
her very large sums of money to do very
little it's a perfect job for a certain
type of MB and led by donkeys found a
number of MPS
uh who were very eager to continue
conversations with this alleged firm
pretend firm and um and I say in the
column it I I think there's it's so
there's a sort of pattern to the people
who who fell for it
um a number of people didn't uh but the
people who sort of fell for it and got
into discussions about money
including Matt Hancock and quasi quateng
and I think there's a deeper lesson
somewhere underneath this
yes and you make the point I think in
your column about actually this is a
cultural problem which is that it's not
just necessarily about sort of greed or
wanting money it's also I think a deeper
problem of the purpose and I think that
was really the sense I got from reading
it I mean explain is there a sort of
vacuum there I mean you know
traditionally 50 years ago MP was a very
highly publicly esteemed position do you
think now that sort of MPS are trying to
find their role in a modern 21st century
age
well I I think that that is part of the
point is uh I say that there's an issue
of Hope an unkind person might say
ambition in Paul
um The Hope is that when somebody's a
bag carrier to a minister they hope that
someday it's it's worth carrying the bag
because someday they will have a person
to carry the bag for them
um and and what heaven that would be
um the the point is in a way this keeps
people on straight and narrow the one
thing that unites all 650 MPS is the
delusion that at some point the country
will call for them
um actually we've got through Prime
Ministers at such a rate in recent years
and it's not such a delusion anymore
um and there are seven figures like
Jeremy corbyn who might suggest that
actually maybe even the most maniacal uh
um uh backbencher might one day be
called to lead their party if not their
country so but but that's that's the one
thing that unites all MPS is is this
sort of belief that maybe at some point
they'll get to the top job the
interesting thing about the sting uh as
it affected Hancock and quateng was
these are two men who clearly recognize
that there is very little future for
them
uh and and the old ways for them to and
this isn't dividing me to excuse the
behavior but I think it's just
interesting that
in the past they might have thought that
they would for instance if they even
didn't get continuing in ministerial
office they would end up on a board of
some company
I suggest in the most charitable way
possible that very few Banks would want
crazy quad to hang on their board
uh very few uh hedge funds would would
like to advertise that they have him as
their one of their advisors so people
like him become slightly desperate
and and there's an interesting thing
underneath this which is that I think
that as the conservative government
dwindles in the next year or two
we will see a lot more of this it's
completely predictable that when people
want an out from politics they become
rather desperate uh and then there's the
question underneath the question
yourself which is perhaps also they
realize that far from having been a
booned to their CV having been an MP
actually doesn't help them at all quite
the contrary it's it it's it's a bit of
a um
a problem for them
well that that that's happened in our
lifetimes the the move from MPS being
people who we respect and whose name you
might want on your Masthead
to uh people who are derided and
actually thought less of because of
their time in the House of Commons
that's it's a very it's a very strange
development but it has happened and I
think that we are seeing sort of Sting
operations of a kind of old-fashioned
tabloid kind and we'll see more of them
a director with the new technology which
Zoom provides where you can have anyone
filming it and of course we also saw in
partygate you know the fact that there
were Zoom screenshots to this Dreadful
December 2020 covert quiz as well
yes absolutely the um the worst party of
all time
um uh yeah I I mean this is all part of
the interconnected age
um I mean there was a time even just 10
years ago when somebody like the fake
Shake of the news of the world would you
know invite a family like Sarah Ferguson
to come to a room at the Dorchester and
and you know produce a handful of cash
and ask her to speak more clearly into
the briefcase and um and and that was a
sort of classic tabloid sting one of the
things was interesting about the the led
by donkey's thing was that this was this
was you know sort of Zoom job interviews
um where I can't hang and Hancock and
others including Gavin Williamson doing
his best attempt at being a human being
um a sort of tried to try to sort of
audition effectively and it was it was a
pretty it was a pretty grotesque
spectacle but it was different from the
old school tabloids things I mean they
actually thought they were in a job
interview and we saw a job interview
live and made it particularly pitiable I
agree and I mean some of those lines in
Matt Hancock ten thousand pound sterling
I mean it sounds very sort of Mr Big The
Italian Job uh kind of thing
I say in the piece I don't think Matt
Hancock's been paid ten thousand Pounds
Sterling or anything else a day other
than when he was in the jungle
I I think his non-jungle rate
[Laughter]
percentage of that Douglas will find our
places don't we
I mean he uh one gets a clearer and
clearer view of what happened and went
wrong in his chancellorship when he said
ten thousand dollars
uh and then they say Sterling yeah
dollars or Sterling it's been squatty
quite 10 with China so these things are
pretty much in parity so maybe maybe he
realized that and then of course he says
uh well I mean uh when I say ten
thousand dollars a month right
what I'm talking about is a ballpark and
then the interviewer says right we're
thinking of eight to twelve thousand a
day and he says uh well I think we're
kind of close to a deal there um I mean
this is this is like profoundly
embarrassing stuff for them but I do
think there's this deeper deeper lesson
underneath it which is this we do have a
I mean for for good reasons in Britain
we have a suspicion of MPS wanting to
make themselves rich
at the same time as having this sort of
rather
um sadistic
um feeling that that they should do
nothing
uh to to advance themselves outside of
the House of Commons and and I think
that that is an oddity in Britain we are
talking um it's always interesting that
we are talking in Britain about
a sort of controversial point but we are
talking about relatively small sums of
money compared to the sums of money
being talked about in other democracies
for instance America I mean Nancy Pelosi
in the United States has become worth
more than 100 million dollars during her
time in the Senate why
uh buying stocks
is she just particularly brilliant at
Trading
I would suggest not she's had very good
information over the decades and so
she's become really rich from politics
that's quite normal in American politics
in British politics there is by contrast
the feeling that if somebody makes a a
six-figure salary outside of their job
as a parliamentarian that they are
absolutely beyond the pale and are doing
something abominable
um I don't share that I think if they're
doing something worthwhile
such as being a varist or a QC that it's
it's okay but the the rules on it the
reason why I say it's a perennial
question is because it just keeps it
coming around and labor of course love
it because they they always pretend it's
Tori's sleaze but I mean if you're a
labor MP and you know you're given a
um a host a hosting slot on the
unlistenable LBC for instance and I paid
a few thousand pounds for it
uh that's okay apparently so I mean
laborer against second jobs unless it's
being a loudmouth uh LBC presenter for a
few hours and getting paid an average
monthly wage for a couple of hours of
shouting your Gob off about things you
don't know about
very proud you know when it's tweeting
uh Jess Phillips of course makes huge
amounts of money per hour by appearing
on things like have I got news for you
as the voice of the people yeah I mean
this is the interesting question I think
it's twofold you know you conclude in
your piece you say basically there isn't
a kind of you know intrinsic thing that
makes Tori supposedly more corruptable
Etc and there's a you know the same
Temptations will apply to labor
especially if they get into office I
mean that's the key divide really is
that no one for a long time I think
perhaps wanted to have Labor's expertise
because they were sort of fighting a
Civil War and particularly unseemly like
that
um but I think it's an interesting shift
that labor has gone from being 100 years
ago it's campaigning for MPS to be paid
so the Working Man could get a salary at
the time the MPS wages one unpaid to now
obviously campaigning on this issue do
you think there's a danger perhaps that
labor is falling into this trap about
having sort of second jobs and second
jobs in the sense of Tory second jobs
which is sort of links with banks links
with consultancies barristers somehow
and actually a difference for the kind
of you know educational public sector
the academic class that makes up so much
of Labor support and ranks in Parliament
yeah I mean I'm not sure that they have
an academic class in the modern labor
party I think that's a mistake would
that there was an academic class in the
modern labor party
um
they the labor party would like to
present this as a Tory sleaze sort of
issue and I say it's just an end of end
of an era issue it happened at the end
of the Blair years at the end of the
Gordon brownies whenever MPS start to
sense that they're on the way out that
they've been that the writing's on the
wall they've in fact that they've been
um weighed in the balance and found
wanting a lot of them just uh leg it and
try to leg it with as much cash as they
can find and that happened as I say at
the end of the late last Labor
government and it's in it's possibly
something that's happening now as it
happened at the end of the conservative
government in the 90s the labor party
would of course always try to present
this as being a a Tory sleaze tofts etc
etc issue but you know as I mentioned
earlier I mean labor MPS are certainly
not immune from this
Jeremy corbyn of course uh tried to
enrich himself people don't think of
this because of course if you if you
there's this perception the sort of the
Tories are capitalists and uh and then
of course capitalism is bad and and
making money is bad of course in Britain
and therefore uh oh we must stop the
Tory is doing this uh the labor party
perfectly open to this Jeremy corbyn
made himself a bit richer by um by um
acting as a mouthpiece for the mullers
in Tehran as a as a paid uh presenter on
press tv and
um the Iranian government propaganda
Channel got chucked off TV stations in
the UK he didn't mind that and and
weirdly enough when he did that people
didn't say aha labor sleaze labor sleaze
they they sort of said that beso poor
old Jeremy accidentally ended up on a
channel where uh
they they do false confessions as the
next segment and after that there's a
there's a nice evening segment of the
hanging of the gays
um so that that everybody just sort of
thought it was just a sort of Mistake by
Jeremy corbyn whereas when the
conservatives try to make money it's
it's a sign of capitalist Wicked
wickedness uh I don't buy that I just
think as I say this is this is what
happens at the end of governments
and um and there'll be more of it I mean
one solution which has been proposed in
the page of The Spectator itself is the
idea of paying MPS more like quite
considerably more what do you think of
that Douglas
I I've always been a fan of that it's an
incredibly unpopular position uh but
I've always been a fan of the idea that
uh MPS should be paid more and the
commencement thing with that is that we
should have fewer of them
um uh we don't need 650 MPS
uh there's no reason why America can get
by on 100 senators and and we need 650
MPS most cmps don't know what to do with
their time
um some do good constituency business
but it's it's it's not a full-time job
um and they make a new sense of
themselves a lot of the time I think
there should be fewer of them they
should be paid a lot more and it would
attract a higher caliber of person
because I mean again a point that needs
reiterating is in our own lifetimes the
status of being an MP has changed
changed from something that was a an
asset on your CV to something that
arguably is is um is something you have
to
um excuse yourself for rather as if you
have on your record you know
police report having exposed yourself in
public it it's something like that and
um I think that's a shame I think we
should have good legislators I think we
should have the best I think the best
people should apply they're clearly not
and
um and one way to solve that is is to
pay what MPS we have better I mean
there's no reason why a diversity
officer in the NHS should be being paid
twice as much as an MP I I think it's
Madness
well thank you very much Douglas joining
us
and finally Posey Parker writes in this
week's magazine about her tour down
under she joins the show to tell us all
about it
hello and thank you for joining us on
spectator TV Posey um I think the first
question is given the events of the the
past week um how are you and what
exactly happened on your trip down under
oh gosh what didn't happen on my trip
down under it was a full spectrum of
experience which started with me when I
landed in Sydney saying to my husband we
could move here it's such a lovely
wonderful friendly place to um by the
end of it leaving New Zealand with pre
police protection where nobody could
even know where I was in the station and
having a police escort until I got on
the plane until the plane took off
so um full spectrum of stuff uh you know
mobbing uh all that stuff
yeah I mean you've obviously done a
number of these kind of events before
you've enlisted reactions a positive
negative before I mean were you
surprised by the intensity of feelings
uh which happened on your tour Down
Under
um yes I was so I look I knew it was
going to be hostile because we are in a
a bizarre episode of human history in
which
um normal people that understand the
truth are fighting against sort of a
quasi-religious authoritarian cult so I
knew that it was going to be difficult
and
but what normally happens in these
situations is you get the the
um
the people that that are part of the
cult that will be very very angry with
you and uh shaped dogmatic mantras at
you uh and that's a that's
understandable and that's I I accept
that and they are almost invited because
they they prove my point really as to
why I don't want them in women-only
spaces but once we stepped into calling
me a white nationalist
um and a Nazi which was done by people
in Authority then I'm fair game just to
be killed in the street so it just took
on a a totally different uh feel and
also I think it most people don't want
men in their spaces they don't want men
in spaces with their daughters and so I
it's unlikely I'm just going to meet
some random person on the street that
doesn't agree with me
um but you know that's that's not the
case when I'm all over the news on a
daily basis trending on a daily basis as
kind of uh more poisonous than a funnel
web spider
and but you mentioned there you know
talking about going around Australia and
New Zealand and you mentioned in your
answer there about those in Authority
who let you down who exactly used to
blame there because obviously there was
a visceral demonstration on the streets
and you talk about in your piece uh but
for the explanation of those who are
watching this um particularly the
failings of the the police in New
Zealand uh why do you think this is and
how exactly do they let you down
well I want to just make it really clear
that the officers that looked after me
in New Zealand were incredible they were
they were lovely
um they are nothing to do with the
decision-making process which basically
held back police
out of the place where the mobbing
happened I mean I got taken to the
middle of the mob
to stand on a Bandstand
um and when I got there I just I had no
idea the police weren't there I just
assumed because they said they cooperate
I mean they said it they they wanted to
know where I was before I got in the
country and so I assumed that meant they
were going to protect me and they took
it really seriously because I'd been
escorted in a couple of airports by
Australian police but instead when I got
there I was searched for two hours and
interrogated my hotel had already
canceled and then when I got to the
hotel when I woke up the next day I had
a threatening letter under my door so I
probably shouldn't have been surprised
and I felt it right I'm not particularly
a spiritual person or believe in those
sorts of things but I felt it in my
bones I was very afraid actually going
to the event
and there was an activist who assaulted
You by pouring tomato juice in your your
head and then gave a very sort of
boastful interview to television before
flying uh to Australia and then the
police said they wouldn't arrest her
arrest them I mean do you think that you
were sort of insufficiently supported
against those kind of kind of threats uh
and that clearly the people who were
doing this sort of stuff felt they were
empowered to do things such as cover you
in tomato juice
I think they they uh act as if there's
no consequences whatsoever and to sort
of gloat about it uh especially when
apparently that person has Refugee
status and now has committed an act of
common assault which uh you know I'm now
drinking my suit cold so I'm quite happy
about that
um I think there are going to be some
consequences but yeah the protesters
should not have been allowed anywhere
near women who just want to speak I mean
it's been called a counter protest we
are not protesting we are just Gathering
to speak
um and so there is a protest against
women speaking uh all in every single
City we encountered and it just got
worse and worse and worse for how much
they were allowed to really terrorize
women
and I mean you know because you've been
you've done a lot of these kind of
overseas tours and around the country as
well I mean do you get a sense perhaps
that the the debate on these kind of
issues is very different in Australia
and New Zealand and to what extent do
you think national leaders people like
just in the Arden are to blame for
clearly they're very powerless and
dangerous state of political debate down
there
well I think um we just look to
lockdowns and I think there's a
correlation between the authoritarian
attitude of those
um governments in lockdown and what you
could force a population to do and this
this adherence to this brand new
um ideology of pretending that we don't
know what biological sex is there does
seem to be a correlation
um I just don't it was just so weird to
be in a a situation that was clearly
very dangerous really violent could have
ended up with any one of us women
um having our lives taken and all over
placards there's uh talking about be me
um dying and being stomped on and
exterminated and all of these things and
that shouldn't have even been allowed at
all but we've lots of Nations have been
allowing this you know whether it's
um how we protest against world leaders
when they come here
um you know more likely to protest Trump
than they were somebody who's uh in a
sort of a theophysistic kind of
authoritarian country uh there's there's
something really bizarre going on and
none of it feels real
sort of hierarchy of different protests
with um perhaps uneven standards between
all of that
um you know yeah from the sound of it
and lies I mean the media in New Zealand
is is nuts they just lied I mean they
didn't they didn't exaggerate they
didn't just exaggerate they didn't just
extrapolate they they actually lied
um they blurred my hand and pretended I
was doing a white power signal they they
whipped up I mean maybe there's no news
in in New Zealand who knows but they
whipped up a frenzy I was I was trending
in those areas and I was on the news
channels every single night with you
know serious politicians coming out and
lying about me and saying that I was a
really dangerous person and never
talking about really any of the issues
that the women want to talk about in
their countries just sort of saying that
I had these uh guilt by association
relationships with a variety of people
that I've never met never talked to I've
got nothing to do with uh and just
whipping people up into this frenzy it's
it's a sight to behold you mentioned the
women there what do they tell you and do
they sort of compare your experiences
with theirs and sort of comment on the
kind of nature of women in political
debate in Australia and New Zealand
yes so
um there's already uh self ID in most of
Australia
um they talk about the sexualization of
children and I saw government literature
where it described babies age naught two
having a sexuality
um and talking about babies sort of
touching their bodies being sort of
forming their sexual identity it's uh
it's truly the worst of everything is
probably in in our Fair Isles is
Scotland and it's it's worse in uh
Australian and New Zealand than it is in
Scotland and Scotland is pretty bad
I mean I think there's a worldwide Trend
in these things where you know it seemed
for a long time like most western
democracies were pushing towards
self-identification and now perhaps in
recent events uh you see obviously the
backlash to what was happening in
Scotland with the gender recognition
Reform Bill
um you've seen the world world Athletics
committee come out against of Elite
Sport transgender participation in that
uh it seems perhaps maybe that there's a
kind of pushback or a sort of change in
the National mood on these Trends did
you detect anything like that in
Australia or New Zealand because it
sounds as though it was very much the
opposite
well it's the same in every country that
it's this weird covert
um attack on policy before it ever
spills out into uh the public discourse
and that's happened in Australia New
Zealand uh a lot worse so before any but
nobody knows what's going on and new
zealanders and Aussies they are really
um I'm not going to say apathetic that
makes them sound like they don't care
but everything's going to be great in
Australia New Zealand everything's fine
everyone just likes each other and gets
on and and so they were ripe really for
this sort of authoritarian creep same in
Canada this authoritarian creep where
they change all the policies nobody
knows what's going on and then they just
push this sort of coercive manipulation
of the population
um and most people are still thinking
that a man who wants to enter a space
which some people might call a trans
woman I would call a man but a man
wanting to use women's spaces and
pronouns and language Etc
a lot of people still think that that is
a really vulnerable member of the
population who needs looking after and
special sort of Rights and the truth is
it isn't a vulnerable member of a
population that can have a mob of 2 000
people commit acts of violence against
women and not even be condemned that is
not a vulnerable part of our population
and how has this sort of impacted you I
mean looking to the future is it going
to change how you you do you conduct
these tours or how you think about them
or how you engage in the public space or
do you remain more Resolute than ever
what's your kind of takeaways and
lessons from the experiences you went
through in Australia and New Zealand
well I'm upping my own personal security
which is
frankly expensive
um so I'm upping my personal security
plus I'm just about to enter politics
and I'm going to go stand against
kirstama so
um I'm going to be even more known
um and I think the attacks upon me are
going to be more vitriolic so that's one
thing I'm doing uh I think unless we get
really good uh agreements from police
when I travel so I'm supposed to go to
Northern Ireland and Ireland
um and now that they've upped the
terrorism threat in Northern Ireland I
think that would be silly to put women
at grave risk so I won't be doing that
but you know I'm going to tell uh the
police in this country that they
absolutely have a duty to look after us
otherwise what we will do as women is we
will stand against every single PCC and
we will win and we will ensure that the
police actually look after women and
that we're safe to speak in the streets
of the United Kingdom
thank you for joining us Posey
for this week if you enjoy spectator TV
subscribe to our YouTube channel click
the Subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap and tap the Bell icon
so you never miss any of our videos
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
thank you